[Music]
at the 2017 Golden Globes et was happy
to help with moet and Chandon
toast for a cause the official champagne
of the Golden Globes donates one
thousand dollars to each celebrities
charity of choice what cause would you
like to toast to I would like to toast
to Planned Parenthood they're needed
important and wonderful work and may it
continue to be supported and continue to
do the work that it does why is that
cause so personal for you how how is
that touched you in your life um I
believe that every woman and everyone
should have access to health care that
keeps them safe that there should be a
place where they feel safe enough to ask
the questions that they have that people
should continue to get screened in the
way that they need to for pap smears and
mammograms etc and not everybody has
access to that health care and Planned
Parenthood is one of the places where
women especially are supported in that
way and I will do everything in my power
to continue to support them as an
organization
I say let's toast to that so you're not
seeing my name Cheers
I'm toasting to plan here in this it's
necessary they've done so much for our
community for women for everybody when I
had questions in my adolescence when I
questioned my teenagers when I had
issues was the safest place to go yes
okay Humane Society and Planned
Parenthood you know you're the third
person to say Planned Parenthood what is
about those charities that are so
special to you for a humane society
because I want to protect all animals
and planet fair to hood because I
believe every woman is entitled to
health care Humane Society upon
Parenthood Cheers